[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the apparent pipe bomb
sent to a variety of prominent Democrats
have received huge media attention in
the past few days and rightly so the
whole thing is horrifying but they are
not isolated acts political terrorism
suddenly seems like part of the
landscape of this country riots
vandalism threats envelopes filled with
white powder physical attacks virtually
every few days brings a new example of
this in this latest case the details
remains sparse but the reaction has been
predictable and depressing you've seen
all the usual dumb people on television
leveraging the moment to make scripted
partisan points or boost their cable
news ratings as they invariably do CNN
blamed Trump for quote inciting a serial
bomber Jeff Zucker a head of that
channel tried to draw a connection
between the president's dislike of the
media and acts of terror in other words
this is what happens when you criticize
us and went on like this all day with
maximum self-righteousness our president
cannot escape special scrutiny he is at
the head of the hate parade and way too
often I could the president has seen for
two years not interested in trying to
detoxify the environment but rather pour
gasoline on the fire I blame the
rhetoric out of that building out of the
White House and it comes from the top
the President of the United States they
say there is no connection between what
Trump has said about Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama Eric Holder John Brennan
and CNN and the thinking of the person
who sent those pipe bombs is foolhardy
yeah so Trump is somehow responsible for
the pipe bombs now they said that over
and over and over normally this kind of
thing would drive Republicans crazy but
this time strangely it didn't they
didn't seem to care very much maybe they
just expected it was coming the
president tweeted back at the media he
blamed them for making America angrier
at his rally last night the crowd
shouted lock her up when he mentioned
Hillary Clinton's name all of it seemed
normal and in fact it was this is all
normal now two parts of the same country
that despise each other so much there's
almost nothing
one can't imagine the other doing
including encouraging acts of terrorism
this is ominous we're not supposed to
hate our fellow Americans this much the
question is how did we get here and
there are lots of reasons our leaders
made a series of terrible decisions and
never apologized for them the middle
class died and nobody noticed new
technologies that were supposed to unite
us instead drove us farther apart a
rotten education system disintegrating
family shocking rates of substance abuse
all of those played a role there were
other factors too but more than anything
our thinking changed that's what really
happened over time we stopped debating
politics issues and ideas and we started
attacking each other for things we can't
change for who we are
take immigration 20 years ago we'd be
arguing about how many migrants to admit
into this country under what
circumstances whether or not it was all
good for America none of that is
seriously under discussion today instead
we get moments like these what is
happening here is a sin against God I
believe that the hypocrisy of all people
of faith in our country not to clamor
for this for what the administration is
doing to end those who selectively use
the Bible to justify this cruelty are
ignoring a central tenet of Christianity
Jesus said suffer the little children
unto me he did not say let the children
suffer a sin against God what you're
hearing is not political debate its
theology it's not based in reason but in
something deeper something less
predictable and more ferocious it's a
religious argument those are not
resolvable that's why you were told not
to start them at the dinner table
religious disputes push people into
extremism if I think your ideas are
wrong I'm happy to argue with you about
them but if I decide you're evil I may
be tempted to hurt you if only in
self-defense
politics like this isn't really politics
it's sectarianism and ultimately it's
statement to violence months ago we
invited congressman bata or work of
Texas onto this show to discuss whether
the United States should provide free
health care to illegal aliens now there
are two sides to that question there
always are two sides to political
questions but a work couldn't even see
the other side he saw only callousness
and sin watch I think there's an
interest in making sure that if someone
is going to be sick if someone needs
help that we deliver it in the most
efficient effective cost effective way
possible
what's the cost effective to pay for the
health care of people yeah I mean you
can pay for it in the emergency room
paying for it at all
yeah well then you can watch people die
in your must be a mean person for not
being in favor congressman thank you for
joining us Bader O'Rourke is not stupid
but like so many in our political class
he has adopted a habit of mind that
leaves no room for legitimate
disagreement with his own views if
you're opposed to paying for health care
for illegal aliens you're in favor of
watching people die you're morally
corrupt why would anyone waste time
trying to reason with a monster like
that would you debate human rights with
Idi Amin of course you wouldn't you
already know where he stands because you
know what sort of person Idi Amin is
facts are irrelevant his character and
motives are all that matter and
increasingly that's what we argue about
character and motive watch this exchange
with congressman Adam Schiff of
California the question we raised was
whether we know conclusively that the
Russian government hacked John Podesta's
email account during the 2016 election
Schiff happens to be one of the few
people who might know the answer to that
he's the ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee watch how he
responded can you look right into the
camera and say I know for a fact the
government of Vladimir Putin was behind
the hacks of John Podesta absolutely the
government of Vladimir Putin was behind
the hacks of our institution and the
dump of John Podesta is not only in the
snow but also in Europe okay you're not
you know what you're dead Tucker look
and say well I know they did jump
and I think that Ronald ray you can't
rolling around Reagan Reagan you're
carrying water for the Kremlin your
cities are loggers on the in somebody
and you can't say they have you're gonna
have to move your shoulder to RT Russian
televisions in other words shift replied
I don't care what you're asking the
question is why you're asking it and the
answer of course is because you're a bad
person in this case a traitor to your
country increasingly most political
conversations look like this when you
want to defeat someone we disagree with
we no longer argue against what they
believe we wait until they make a
mistake until they say something stupid
even unintentionally and then we pounce
we don't consider their explanation we
refuse to accept their apologies there
is no forgiveness the point is not to
make things right or to improve anything
the point is to vanquish an enemy now
what should be said it's not just
Democrats who do this though obviously
they do leave the category lock her up
that's not something any politician can
do or should do even to Hillary Clinton
criminal guilt is for courts and judges
to decide it has to be and what about
this the Reverend John Kasich he's the
Republican governor of Ohio watch him
explain that when you disagree with him
you are really disagreeing with God
we've got to start putting ourselves in
the shoes of other people we've got to
start thinking about the consequences
that others suffer and if we've been
spared those by the grace of God let us
be let us be appreciative let us count
our blessings and let us reach out to
those who have less and let's stop
putting up walls around ourselves and
not understanding the plight the trouble
and the problems of others it is not
right and the Lord doesn't want it and
our people at their hearts want to reach
out to others look at what they do in
these storms they go and they risk the
people they don't know they put them in
their homes they feed them that's
America the Lord doesn't want it says
pastor Kasich well maybe father Kasich
is right it's really hard to know what's
easy to know and to foresee is what
happens to a country where the
people in power claim moral authority
they don't have in order to compel you
to obey what happens resentment builds
factions form craziness starts to seem
normal it is all bad and if you want to
fix it stop talking like this